this is a personal question it's a it's
a weird thing I grew up airport like
dirt [ __ ] before yeah like nothing
yeah and uh
so when I was 16 I moved out on my own
yeah uh started started my life and
every day my you know my dad was still
working my mom was a drug addict she
overdosed she died I'm sorry and uh it's
probably best yeah I understand and uh
but every day I woke up I said I'm gonna
I'm not gonna be like that right I'm
gonna that became your driver I
understand so but now today yeah I have
a hundred million dollar appraisal
company yeah I do the appraisals from
everybody out there good for you it's
awesome
and super successful great company real
happy but every single day I wake up I
still feel like that little [ __ ] poor
that's good I hate it well okay so then
you need to if you hate it you need to
go deeper you need to either go into
therapy I mean this is real like you got
to get the poison out
I just successful company successful
successful isn't this successful is this
but I'm happy with my wife I'm happy
with my kids we have a great assembly so
are you are you tired by of having the
chip on your shoulder or is it deeper
than that I'm tired of having a chip on
my shoulder here's what I believe and I
could be wrong I believe that you can't
do this to your wife or others this is
why I believe in therapy or some other
version or some other version if you
have a stigma on that here's what I
believe I believe people don't realize
by actually saying something out loud
and getting the poison out I believe
there's three to four things that are
deeply inside of you that you've never
said at all
that are completely predicated on your
mom dynamics that the second they come
out of your [ __ ] mouth whether on an
Instagram video to the world because
you're like [ __ ] it I'm gonna tear this
whole thing down or yep or by going and
sitting with somebody in a private room
or however the [ __ ] you or going to a
[ __ ] Forest by yourself and screaming
it at the top of your lungs I don't care
how you do it I promise you without
knowing all the details there's poison
in you that you've never said out loud
I'm sure I'm sure what I'm just saying
this was hard so I could see it yeah
brother
what there nobody's gonna judge you on
that like like this is why I always tell
people to put out all their [ __ ]
skeletons because that's the [ __ ]
jail
there's no amount of money and success
you're going to make that's going to fix
that
you got to get the poison out and people
do it in different ways I think some
people need to [ __ ] say it to the
whole world because even therapy is
still kind of in a closed box you know
yourself but I'm telling you until you
say it there's people go therapy or for
10 years and never say it until you say
it you gotta [ __ ] say it yeah until
the poison comes out of your mouth it's
inside of you and what's scary is just
getting it out of your mouth I've
watched so many [ __ ] people win that
game but it's hard the reason it's still
there bro the reason it's still in there
is because it's hard if it's so easy to
say it right now you always think
getting successful will make it go away
because people think the outside fixes
it it's the inside yeah you gotta get
the [ __ ] poison out yeah got it thank
you get the poison out bro